hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only bob proctor
enjoy
i had an affirmation that i used for
years still use it i'm so happy and
grateful now that money comes to me in
increasing quantities through multiple
sources on a continuous basis
i am so happy and grateful now that
money comes to me in
in increasing quantities through
multiple sources on a continuous basis
and i just keep repeating that like a
mantra
and you're right out you know i'm so
happy and grateful now that
i have in my possession a million
dollars and that's where you started out
intellectually
then you get emotionally involved and if
you keep doing that ultimate you're
going to attract the money you could
spend
oh god nine minutes
if you just write down write it write
this down right now i am so happy and
grateful
i am so happy and grateful
now that i have
multiple sources of income
i am so happy and grateful now that i
have multiple sources of income
you know
if you write that out every day
for the next 30 60 days
you're going to become
very very aware of having multiple
sources of income
wealthy people all have multiple sources
they don't have one or two they have a
whole bunch of them
i don't know how many sources of income
i got i'm not even interested in
figuring it out because somebody else
looks after that i don't look after it
but i do know that you can do that
that's what keith did it down in new
orleans god he just
his life changed so dramatically
and
i'll show you different things you can
do because anyone can
you want to set up multiple sources of
income i failed lots of times you don't
learn from your successes you'll learn
from your failures you get up and got it
again so you're not a failure until you
quit
failing is not hitting the mark but that
doesn't mean you're a failure
you failed but you didn't you don't
become a failure the only time you fail
here is if you quit you don't quit
you'd have to shoot me
to stop me i mean there's no quitting it
doesn't it's not part of the deal
there's no excess exit strategy you know
where you're going that's where you're
going to get there fail a number of
times i failed miserably if you feel big
enough it's exhilarating
i mean i've got some real beauties
does that help
you just you just get up and get going
don't you dare lay down
and i don't care if you blow everything
you got listen i lost everything i had
one time and i um
so clear to me i sat in the living room
i closed the front drapes i sat in the
dark in a great big chair
probably for better part of a month
i was so despondent
i had lost
and then i don't know what moved me
but
i got moved i went and i got
two long playing records
earl nightingale's
narration not condensed narration is
narration
of the book as a man thinketh by james
allen
and i put those records on i started to
play them
i got up i opened the curtains
and i went and bought a brand new
cadillac car
i didn't have any money
but i knew the card made me feel good
when i got in it
and i went to work
that's very clear man that was a long
time ago
yeah
just get up and keep going
if it's big enough you mean you're gonna
you'll grow you you don't just grow from
your successes
it's the trouble maybe grow we only have
one problem in the whole world and
that's ignorance they're living in
ignorance they don't know that what
they're doing is going to keep them
where they are
and they keep doing it
because they don't know how to change
they're overwhelmed with the debt
people are saying i need the money they
haven't got it
they want to take their family on a
vacation they don't have the money to go
so they may borrow and go anyway now
they got more debt
they have to understand
that they don't have to live that way
i wrote a book called you're born rich
the truth is you are
most people are just a little short of
money but you are born rich rich in
potential anybody can go to our site go
to bob proctor.com you can download the
book you were born rich
free it won't cost you a cent and
chapter 2 is how much is enough there's
a it's described very well how to get
out of debt
you've got to create a debt repayment
program where it's all done
automatically
and then you focus on prosperity you've
got to have a financial goal you've got
to work toward it and you've got to
understand
that you can earn more than you're
earning
and wealthy people don't have one source
of income they have more than one
i was earning money all last night while
i was sleeping yeah you can actually
earn more money when you're sleeping
than you can spend when you're awake you
know it sounds like a cute line but it's
true
there's no end to what we can earn
if you are not getting information from
someone who is already wealthy then
you're probably getting information from
the wrong people most people ask their
brother-in-law or the guy next door the
girl they know
how to earn more hell if they knew
they'd be earning it they don't know
and most people talk to people that
don't know carlisle put it very well he
said he did not believe in the
collective wisdom of individual
ignorance
and that's where most people are getting
it from people who don't know anymore
themselves
i think you have to go that's why these
seminars are so important today
people have the opportunity to go and
learn most people won't pay to go
i tell people listen you invest in this
it'll probably be the important money to
do it it's probably the last time you'll
ever have to borrow money let the sand
and the glass here represent
your life
the sand in the top of the glass
represents the future
the sand in the bottom of the glass
represents the past now here's the odd
thing about this you don't know how much
sand you have left in the top of the
glass
you may think you have a lot you might
only have a little
you may think you only have a little and
you might have a lot we don't know
this is gone you can do nothing about it
the only thing you can do is watch right
here right now right in the center
if a person's listening to me right now
they can make a decision to change right
now just make the decision you don't
have to know how
you don't have to know where the money's
going to come from you don't have to
know where the resources come from
just make a decision
and then decide
what you want
how do you find your life
ah your life's purpose
you don't find it you you well you do
find you discover it
our purpose
this is interesting
your life's purpose is your reason for
living
um
i like the way my
uh good friend says it
and
how did he put it the two most important
days in your life
of the day you're born
and the day you decide or discover why
you were born les brown says that all
the time
and i like him when he says that now
the day you're born the two most
important
two most important days the day you're
born they discover why you're born
your purpose is why you get out of bed
in the morning your purpose is while
you're living
i obviously have found my purpose i love
what i do i absolutely love it i'm
passionate about it i help people
understand who they are how to change
their life how to go from being broke to
becoming wealthy being unhappy to be
happy how to be in a bad vibration to be
in a good vibration
that that is my purpose i've studied it
i love it i live it
most people
have never discovered why they're here
how do you discover it you sit down and
totally relax
get yourself a pad
and a little pen
and put it somewhere
beside a chair a favorite chair
discipline yourself maybe at the same
time every day early in the morning to
go and sit there and the only thing you
put in this pad
is what comes to your mind and ask
yourself it's a little game you play
if i could do what i loved
every day that's all i do is what i love
every day
i come in here into this studio that i'm
in this studio's in my backyard i can
broadcast all over the world from here
now
my company built it for me
this is what i do and ask yourself if i
could do what i love all day
what would it be
that's where your purpose that's where
you're going to find your purpose
that's where you're going to find it
i watched i'll give you a good example i
watched a
very pretty woman
being interviewed on television and
she
had been a dancer
in a chorus
a chorus line
and she said you know
i was a pretty good dancer but i wasn't
the best i knew i was always going to be
in the chorus
i would never be the star because that
wasn't that good
and she said i liked it
but i didn't really love it
and she said i sat down one day and i
thought what do i really love to she
says i love baking pastry
quite a switch from dancing
she got out of the dancing business she
moved to france and went to work with
some of the best pastry chefs in the
world now when i saw her being
introduced or interviewed she was one of
the top pastry chefs in the world she
was doing what she loved that's what you
gotta do you gotta find out what do you
love
that's what you're gonna be passionate
about and that's what you should be
doing
and it doesn't matter whether you're
earning any money on it or not
you see
you don't earn money from working that's
a myth and it's not a very good one it's
a belief of most people and it's a silly
one you earn money by providing service
you can you can earn more money when
you're sleeping than you could spend
when you're awake if you learn how to
provide the service if you see a large
group of people going one way and one or
two going the other way follow the one
or two wow
the others have never known where
they're going to go
97 of the population struggle all the
way through life
school doesn't teach us how to take
control of our life i don't care where
you go and i don't care how long you go
how far you go in school it does not
teach us how to control our self
we've got to get involved with self
really understand who we are
um
so
everything every time you would caution
you you look around you see it it's all
around you right everybody's telling you
you're crazy you can't do that
you know
and when i quit the fire department i
quit the fire department going to clean
offices everybody thought i'd really out
of my mind in fact i was really
questioning myself at one point
because
i was the second person since 1934 to
quit the fire department
no one quit that job and they couldn't
fire you i mean it was like having a
pension and you only worked half the
time
you know and when you were working at
night you'd sleep i mean it was like
being retired
because i was in a slow hall if you're
in a busy place and that's different
downtown toronto would not be a good
place
but at any rate
i got into that
and i thought i can't stay here
because they were sitting around doing
nothing wanting to play cards or play
darts and
i think i know i got to do something i
got to do something so i eventually quit
and i went and
started cleaning offices how do we keep
positive and
motivated in the journey
of cleansing our paradigms towards our
soul how do you keep
a
sustained level of enthusiasm
in this journey that actually requires
quite a lot of profound internal work
i think you were
said the right word there in enthusiasm
i think people are looking for
excitement
yeah yeah very well and there's quite a
big difference
absolutely i've always pointed out when
you see a person that gets excited when
something good happens you're going to
see somebody gets depressed when
something bad happens
and
there's a great lesson in that
but rather than getting
excited we should get enthused we want
to look where enthusiasm comes from it
comes from
in theos which is in spirit
and everything just is
and if we can look at it it just is it's
neither good nor bad
it just is we're not going to get
excited we'll get enthused
and if we look at
the negative it just is
it's not going to depress us because it
just is
so i think the trick there is to
understand the difference between
enthusiasm and
excitement and how do you maintain the
enthusiasm i think the only way to
maintain it is to continually study who
you are
never stop studying
and now
i don't think you just sit and study do
nothing else
you have to study you have to study
understand and you have to apply it
so it all comes out in results
now i have found a great way to measure
results is in money
you can measure it to the penny
people say happiness or health you can't
measure a person's happiness
and you cannot measure their health
you can go and you can have a checkup
and they'll say guy's in perfect health
he walks out of the doctor's office a
bag he drops dead
he wasn't in perfect health at all
it appeared he was
and
but in earning money you provide service
but you got to control the money you
don't let the money control you
and then
if you fall in love with the idea of
providing service and it's in a
profit-making way
you can earn a lot of money well then
you can put that money to work to do
great things with
and that's sort of the path i'm on
and
like my partner and i we build schools
over in africa
and we do them through cynthia kersey
out there in los angeles is the
unstoppable foundation
and um
we take a lot of joy in that
we have people from the company go over
and see the work that we're doing you
know that they're contributing to
so i think you um
you've got to keep checking your results
and you have to keep raising your own
level of awareness and the only way to
do that is to continually study
and but control your life don't let life
control you
so you're living from the inside out
which sounds very esoteric or
philosophical
but it's the only way i can explain it
because that's really what you're doing
because most people use their
imagination they use it the wrong way
they imagine
what won't work they imagine something
bad happening
um
what should we imagine more often every
day we should imagine you should
see yourself where you want to be
you got to live there
there's a great book
you may be familiar with stella adler's
book the art of acting
oh gosh you've got to get it stella
adler was a great acting teacher she was
a method acting teacher she did she
studied and understands lasky the the
russian acting teacher that originated
method acting
um marlon brando wrote the forward in
her book he was the first
method actor to reach super stardom okay
and
he wrote forward in her book now still
adler never actually wrote a book a man
named
uh kissel
took all of her teaching all her lessons
for teaching and she put them into it or
he put them into a book so when you read
her book you're going to reacting
classes
and
like shakespeare said we're all actors
you know the world's the stage when
that's true
well when you reach a goal you're going
to act like you're already there
it's already happened intellectually the
second you think about it
it's already happened emotionally when
you're emotionally involved with it so
it's only a period of time until it
manifests in physical form
but because it's not in physical form we
act like them got it yet yeah well so
that's why most people stay stuck
because they're acting like they haven't
got it yet
or
if i can't act like that lewis would see
that i haven't got that result he'll
he'll think i'm phony
i'm gotta quit worrying about what lewis
thinks and start concentrating on what
bob thinks
and so
you see yourself your imagination you
gotta be that person
gertie said that great philosopher he
said before you can do something
universe must be something so you've got
to be it intellectually you've got to be
it emotionally that's like solomon says
as a person things in their heart the
emotional mind
well it's only a period of time then to
manifest physically that's one of the
first laws of the universe is the
perpetual transmutation of energy energy
is moving into form
always
to form moving into form through form
back into form again
so
we cause it all to happen the way we
think and the way we stay locked into
ideas you know
how should people be
developing their imagination on a daily
basis
in a positive way well i think they
should take time to image what they want
i have a business partner um sandy
gallagher who's a brilliant woman
and she rides horses
gated horses
and she's in kentucky right now
in big
term
shows there
she images herself as a world champion
every day
she takes the time and she sees herself
as a world champion
she sees yourself getting the roses
getting the whole thing
and that's where you should do it
i think you build the image of what you
want
i mean you obviously imaged this
studio before you ever built it right i
mean everything you see here was part of
the image in your mind but everything
you create you create twice
what's in here what's out here
you know
so you never get an original painting
you always get a duplicate the picture's
in here wow
so we have to see ourselves with what we
want here
now we've got enormous
uh
deterrent
in our paradigm we're conditioned
genetically and environmentally
and that conditioning is controlling
most people's lives that's why brilliant
people are broke brilliant people are
unhappy brilliant people never really
accomplish very much they're absolutely
brilliant
but their paradigm is controlling them
it's all about intellect
they're smart people
but like
you got to consider where we come from
a little particle of energy from a
little particle of energy from dead come
swimming
that's the nucleus of us
then that goes on for 280 days
attracting more energy until
you
make your debut on the planet and then
you're programmed environmentally by
your environment
so everything that's going on is going
right into your subconscious mind so you
come out you're programmed genetically
we go we don't know how far it goes back
four or five generations possibly like
when i was young man i had red hair
my mother didn't have red hair my dad
didn't have red hair i got a brother and
sister and they don't have red hair
because you think well
but my mother's father and all his
brothers had red hair
so sometimes it jumps a generation
that's why we look like our relatives
it's genetic conditioning
and then there's environmental
conditioning
we know almost all welfare recipients
are fourth fifth generation welfare
recipients
so this is passed down generation to
generation
now unfortunately we're all or
fortunately we're all exactly the same
we got exactly the same potential our
spiritual dna is perfect you know ralph
waldo trine wrote a great book in tune
with the infinite
and in that book he says nothing is good
or bad except your thinking makes it so
there's a law of life called love
polarity that law decrees everything has
an opposite
i'm inside the studio there'd be no
insight if there wasn't an outside
you couldn't have enough without a doubt
you couldn't have a heart without a cold
well he says nothing's good or bad
except your thinking makes it so
the truth is everything just is
it just is
if you go and ask the theologian whereas
god was god he says god is that's it
that's all they can tell you
the most astute theologian in the world
that's all it is god is
you don't ask the scientist
what's energy energy is that's that they
don't even know what energy is it is
that's it
well everything that happens in our life
it just is and then our perception of it
is going to dictate whether it's good or
bad
if we look for the good we're going to
find
it if we look for the bed we're going to
find that
well we have to train ourselves we have
to program ourselves to look for the
good
and you're going to find it if you could
go back and with all the wisdom that
you've gained over the years if you
could go back and tell 10 year old bob
some advice give them some advice based
on everything that you've learned what
advice would you give them
set a goal
i always have a goal
i have in my pocket a gold card
i've been carrying a gold card in my
pocket for years
since 1961.
when you decide on a goal
you paint the picture in words
when you do that you impregnate the
picture into a group of cells in your
brain
every time i touch that gold card it
triggers the picture in my mind
and as long as that picture is there i
keep moving in direction of it
and that is really the secret i think
to living a good life you've got to have
a reason for it when you wake up in the
morning you have to have a good reason
for waking up and going to going to work
feeling is a word we invented to
describe our conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in
when you are feeling bad you're in a
negative vibration
when you're feeling good you're in a
positive vibration that's just a basic
thing that we could go by
so
how do you feel good well there's all
kinds of ways to feel good
think
of something really pleasant you'll
start feeling good do something kind for
somebody you'll start to feel better
help somebody out somewhere you'll start
to feel good
share a good idea you'll start to feel
good
when you're feeling good you're in a
good vibration you're going to attract
good stuff to you
most people don't understand that
feeling is conscious awareness of
vibration and the vibration you're in is
dictating what you're going to attract
oh
it's a basic thing it's so basic
but it's not understood now focus
is an act of the mind
you have a will
a will you have perception reason
imagination memory intuition and the
will
the will gives you the ability to focus
on one thing
how do you do that
most people if they focused on one thing
for more than three seconds they'd
probably set a family record most
people's their minds all over the place
the most successful people are very
focused
if you take and put a little dot with a
pen or a marker on the wall offset your
favorite chair don't tell anybody you're
doing if they see it
they'll think it's a flyer someone won't
pay any attention but put a little
black dot or ink dot on the wall
opposite your favorite chair when you're
sitting in the chair practice totally
relax and stare at that black dot just
stare at that black dot now you're going
to find your mind will wonder you only
stare at it for a millisecond and your
mind will be gone somewhere you'll hear
something a sound a siren and your
mind's gone
break don't feel bad about it bring it
right back to the dot bring back the dot
bring back and every time you sit in
that chair now if you'll turn turn that
into a habit
i guarantee you you'll become strong
focus
i was working i was out on the
golf tour with one of the pros
and um we were sitting around a room the
night between the two rounds
and he asked me about that that's what i
taught him
i said sim relax and i went to the
opposite wall and i put a little dot in
the wall now i said focus on that
there's another way of doing it light a
candle in a candle holder and put the
candle
somewhere near your favorite chair and
just stare at the flame
keep concentrating on the flame until
you become one with the flame
find your mind wander bring it back to
the flame now that's how you focus and
what you're doing is you're
strengthening your will
when you do this you're strengthening
your will
and
once you get it strong you know you can
keep making it stronger it's like
anything it's like your body you
exercise it'll get strong and if you
don't it'll get very lethargic
develop your will that's how that's how
you develop the focus and can you
provide an affirmation well i
anybody can make an affirmation it's
just a positive statement from yourself
to yourself i always like i'm happy and
grateful i am so happy and grateful now
that
i have the ability to focus and i don't
take my mind off my focus so you see
when you see this and you know this and
you can focus that's when you're away to
the races the one thing you need if you
want to move higher
is a greater awareness
[Music]
people are not earning a hundred
thousand a year because they want to
earn a hundred thousand a year
earning a hundred thousand a year
because they're not aware of how to earn
a hundred thousand a month
people aren't alone and lonely because
they enjoy being alone and lonely
they're alone and lonely because they're
not aware of how to build meaningful
relationships
people don't struggle all of their
commercial career
because they enjoy struggling they're
struggling because they're not aware
of how to knock those blocks down that
are all inside it's never outside it's
never another person it's never a
condition or a circumstance
it's always lack of awareness
this is such beautiful information
i've been living with it for a long time
i don't even know how you'd live without
it
in fact i don't think you can you merely
exist and unfortunately that's the way
most people go through life
do you see our educational institutions
is not giving us the same kind of
information they really don't they
really believe the secret is read the
book
remember what's in the book and be able
to repeat it answer the questions
more right than wrong you'll pass you
get the degree well we've got people
graduating from some of the most
prestigious universities in the world
every year
with multiple degrees
they're having difficulty finding work
that are broke how does that happen
and yet you'll find other people who are
functionally illiterate they can either
read the right they're earning millions
how do we account for this
you're going to find that out
as you study this
it's got nothing to do with anything
outside of ourselves
education isn't answering what's in the
book
education comes from the latino juco
meaning to reduce to develop or to draw
from within remember i said everything's
already here omnipresent that's within
us madam montessori was right
napoleon hill was right
carnegie knew the right question
hill knew how to answer it
what are you going to do with the rest
of your life
that's your question
you got to make a decision what's the
thing that you don't want to learn and
understand that you feel like you know
what i haven't fully grasped this
concept or idea and i really want to get
to another level
well i'm always wanting to get to
another level hopefully i'm at a higher
level today than i was yesterday i i'm
in here
around 5 30 every morning studying wow
that's how i start my day here
well you see
there is no end to the growth
you you always want to grow
so
you're created in god's image
now there's a problem with this
because we're raised on our physical
senses
we grow up
and what we've done is had god created
in our image in our mind
not that we're creating god's image
we're taught that we created god
in our image
so now we're trying to figure out how
can the man be omnipresent
how can that person be everywhere and
because we're locked in on a physical
level we get lost
when we understand
that you have infinite potential there
is no top
there's no beginning no end
see when it comes to school of greatness
there is no finish line
when it comes to personal development
so how can you tell how well you're
doing by the result you're getting
by their fruit by their food you'll know
them by the results they're getting
if they're not getting the results they
don't know
so if you're going to get a mentor get
somebody that's getting the results yeah
or you don't want him i just see here on
page six it says money is a servant
it's a servant
now there's a myth about money
says another myth about money like you
accept money is that it only comes as a
result of luck or good fortune
well of course that is really silly
that's not true at all but that's the
concept that a lot of people operate
with
okay
now if you move over onto page seven
we're talking about money's got to
circulate it's not only a server you got
to keep it moving
i have some money here in my pocket
i keep it a little envelope
and
this stuff here
is money the truth is this represents
money
now this used to be paper now i think
it's plastic you know use it as a fan
but this is
it's a servant and you can put this to
work
you've got to keep it circulating
now we tell a story in here
about
mr chapman now mr chapman was an
interesting guy
he lived on the street that i lived on
as a little boy
and my brother and i had a paper route
and we sold
papers to the people on that street we
had 300 customers went right from
kingston road to the lake ontario
and almost every house we had as a
customer
mr chapman had a big house not too far
from our house up on a hill it was an
old house
and one day mr chapman we used to feel
sorry for him he was he was hunched back
he was a little man he used to push a
little cart around and he collected junk
his wife was a a tall thin lady
and
she always wore just
skimpy clothes like
a cotton dress with a maybe a little
coat running shoes
and she would be off up the street she
went to clean houses or clean offices
we thought they were really poor
well one day we opened the paper we went
up the corner to get the papers and when
we got the delivery of the papers it was
headlines that mr chapman had died
it was a headline in the toronto star
they found a hundred thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars in a jar in the
house here he is collecting junk and he
had a hundred thousand dollars in a jar
in the house
now i just looked up that that up this
morning that's equal to one million
eighty-seven thousand seven hundred
ninety eight dollars in today's dollars
that's what a hundred thousand in 1947
would have been uh in today's dollars
it'd be over a million a million eighty
seven
eighty eight thousand
he had all this money and he had it in a
jar
it was serving no one it wasn't
circulating
we were shocked that he even had it
so
what we've got to understand is that
saving it like that is silly like here
the money that's in this envelope in my
pocket it's useless as long as it's in
an envelope in my pocket it does no one
any good
you may be saying why are you keeping it
there it won't stay
it won't stay there very long i'll have
it circulating in a very short period of
time
now if you come down to the bottom of
page nine these are just basics we're
talking about here about a prosperity
consciousness exercise
now that we have touched upon some of
the characteristics of money let us turn
briefly to a simple technique
which you can begin using immediately to
start attracting the amount of money
that you desire now think of that
you can literally attract to you
the amount of money you desire you've
got to ask yourself
where do i stand with money although you
cannot change conditions or circumstance
you don't have to let them control you
we can't control what's going on outside
but we can control what's going on
inside
you know
and
unfortunately i don't think many of us
have been raised to really understand
that yeah
and it's a lack of understanding that's
causing all our problems
you know
but i mean how can you say that to
someone who's like well i don't feel
like i have control on the inside when
it seems like everything has power over
me
what's something that could start to
shift
you see the truth is for for that person
that would be true
that they're being controlled by outside
we
look at it this way we are the only
creature on the planet
that's totally disoriented in our
environment
all the little squirrels the birds the
every all the animals
are completely at home in their
environment they blend in
you and i are totally disoriented in our
environment we've been given the mental
faculties to create our own environment
however we go right through school and
we've never learned that
we have higher faculties
and the average person has no knowledge
of how to operate with them how to
develop them we have perception the will
reason imagination memory and intuition
now those mental faculties they're not
just words
they're actually mental faculties that
we can use
to take control over our world and to
create the environment that we want
but unfortunately we grow up we don't
know that we've been raised to live
through by what we see hear smell taste
and touch
our physical senses and we've been
raised to be controlled by what's going
on outside
as little kids will you listen to what
i'm telling you will you look at this
you know and so it's all outside
um we get our report card and that tells
us what kind of student we are
but it really tells us where our mind
was at for a few minutes three weeks ago
got nothing to do with who we are
so i think we're
we're raised in ignorance actually
there's a very small percentage of the
population that
have a reasonably
clear understanding of who they are and
what they're capable of doing but
the ones that do are in the minority
first of all the cause of fear is
ignorance
that is the cause of fear
and so if you follow the ignorance it
doesn't start out as fear
the ignorance starts out in a conscious
level as doubt and worry
that's on a conscious level we're
doubting or we're worrying then we take
whatever image comes into our
consciousness of the doubt and the worry
and we turn it over to our emotional
mind that's what causes the fear
well that fear then has to be expressed
through the body to the only instrument
it can be expressed through our physical
body it sets up a vibration known as
anxiety
anxiety is not expressed anxiety becomes
suppressed we suppress it
and the suppression then turns to
depression
which turns to disease which turns to
decay you see you're talking about a
track a person gets on it's a very
negative track
it's ignorance
don't worry
fear
anxiety suppression depression disease
disintegration
now the polar opposite of all that
the opposite of ignorance is knowledge
there's only one way to get to knowledge
and that is to study
now unfortunately
school
didn't do the job that it was designed
to do for most of us
schools should teach us to love to study
not to dread studying and homework and
tests
they should teach us to love it
because study leads to the opposite of
don't worry which is understanding
see it's study that leads to
understanding we understand how to
handle the fear
it's understanding
that enables us to cause us to
understand where the fear starts
the understanding
then
we want to say what do we understand we
want to understand this whole universe
operates by law
one of the laws is the law of opposite
the opposite of don't worry is
understanding
now if the don't worry leads to fear
what's understanding leads to
understanding leads to faith
the faith leads to
expression
well-being
and expression
it's not depression
it's not suppression it's not anxiety
the faith leads to well-being
the well-being then is expression
acceleration because we're at ease we're
not at there's not disease so you're
dealing with polar opposites there's two
different sides to things
and when we understand that
our world starts to change
just by understanding that we learn how
to deal with these pandemics when they
hit
and they will hit there will be others
there always has been all down through
history if you look back
there's been things like this happen in
the past
and unfortunately the masses are sort of
paralyzed by it i once read where
it said no amount of reading or
memorizing is going to make you
successful
it's the understanding and application
of why something came
you're going to study
this i study it every day
every day
for at least an hour
sometimes more but at least an hour
it's a habit
habit something you do unconsciously you
don't even spend any time thinking about
it you just do it you get dressed by
habit
you shower comb wash your hair
do you know good habits
automatically transform our life see the
purpose of a goal is not to get
it's not to reach the goal
it's the awareness that you develop as
you go after it
you're learning who you are
it's becoming aware of who you are
yeah
i was in a seminar years and years ago
and uh there was the speaker bill gove
bill gove
was considered the
frank sinatra public speakers he was
incredible he had a handheld mic
and he's looking at the audience and he
said
if i want to be free
i've got to be me
not to me i think you think i should be
not to me i think my kids think i should
be
not to me i think my wife thinks i
should be if i want to be free
i've got to be me
he said i'd better know who me is what
would you want someone to do straight
after they stop listening to this
episode
as they go back into their own life
after listening to you today what do you
want them to do what do you who do the
who do you want them to be where would
you like them to start
i'd like to ask them to ask themselves
what do i really want in this life
what do i really want
and take a pen
and write it down
[Music]
what do i really want in this life
they might start out
what do i love doing
i think that's where you start your
purpose in life is what do you love
i'm living my purpose so your purpose is
why you're alive why you get out of bed
in the morning
and some people never figure that out
they never even give it any thought
when it's
probably the most important question a
person can ask themselves
if you start out what do i really love
doing that's a good place to start
you know i had a
doctor here
probably a couple of years ago now in
phoenix
he was in a seminar and he said
he was telling me he was thinking of
quitting the medical profession i said
why are you going to quit
well he said you got to put in a lot
more time to earn less money today and i
said well i've heard that
he said the medical profession's all
messed up and they said well i've heard
that too
i said why did you become a doctor
well he said i love it
why would you want to quit
well he said because you can't earn i
said wait a minute i said if you're
doing what you love
if you never earned a dime
you're spending your days doing what you
love to do that's the trick of life
i said your problem is you think you
earn money by going to work you work to
earn money you don't work to earn money
people earn the most money don't work at
all
you earn money by providing service
but you gain satisfaction from doing
what you love
and there's two forms of income one
satisfaction the other is money
it's a material
thing but i said if you're not getting
satisfaction what you do you should quit
it
because they said
that's where it comes in that's why we
should figure out what we love to do
and then dedicate our life to it
i got into this business i had been
studying it for quite a while
and i had the opportunity already
mentioned a visiting early night yale
and i was leaving his office right at
the end and i said earl what is the big
deal in life
well he said there isn't any big deal
bob he said
it's simply a matter of sitting and
figuring what you love to do and
then dedicate your life to it so the
problem with most people is they never
figure out what they love to do well i'm
telling i could feel the hair going up
in the back of my neck i knew exactly
what i'd love to do i would love to do
what he was doing i was and i wanted to
do it with him
i had a very busy company at the time
we were operating canada the u.s and
england
but i knew that i was finished doing
that i was going to come back i was
going to work with him two years later i
was his vice president of sales i wanted
to do in the what he was doing be in the
business he was in
and that's where i made the decision and
i love it i love what i do
now
that's what people should be doing what
do i love to do then dedicate your life
to it now you earn money by providing
service you earn money while you're
sleeping just figure out how to serve
people
you don't have to be there you don't
have to physically be there and do it
you can serve people while you're
sleeping and get paid
and that's how you're in money so you
got to learn how to earn money but that
has got nothing to do with
a life
of living which allowed that's the first
place so if i was telling anybody sit
down figure out what you love to do and
then make up your mind you're going to
dedicate your life to it
what stops most people what they love to
do they think you can't earn any money
at it that doesn't matter
[Music]
forget about the money
that's another subject figure out how to
earn it go talk to people and know how
to earn money i know how to earn money i
could teach people how to earn money but
that is not the thing it's to provide
service
so the most important thing
what do i love to do sit down what would
i really love to do how would i love to
spend my life
that's what we should do
and unfortunately
most people never get involved in that
exercise see you're a spiritual being
that's who you are you're a pure
unadulterated spirit
you're an extension an expression of god
whatever your concept of god is we see
god as everything
the
all-knowing power that's all-powerful
all-knowing omnipresent and you're a
spiritual you're you're you're a
spiritual expression
and as such
all knowledge is with you you have all
knowledge you have all power
you just
don't believe it
and to the degree that we believe it we
have it
and the trick of life i see is
developing our belief system
our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something and frequently
if we re-evaluate a situation our belief
about that situation will change
it took me nine and a half years to
figure that out
i was sitting having something deep with
valve vandal he was a
marvelous mentor of mine
and i had been reading the bible the new
testament the old testament the book of
mormon the
bhagavad-gita the quran the torah i mean
i was seriously studying on all this
because there's only two sources of
reference you can go to to find out
about yourself one science and the other
theology
and they all teach you essentially the
same thing they come at it from
different angles
and in everyone everywhere they tell you
got to believe belief is an absolute
prerequisite you don't believe it ain't
going to happen
well
i'm thinking how do you believe i mean
i'd ask somebody how do you believe them
they don't know that
how do you believe
i was having something to eat with him
one day in the restaurant i can still
see the two of us sitting there and in
idle conversation that came out he said
our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something and frequently
if we reevaluate a situation our belief
about that situation will change
well all it was just like rockets going
off in my head
i got him to repeat what he said and i
realized that's why my life had changed
i was studying this non-stop non-stop
nonstop everything i kicked my hands get
my hands on so i was continually
reevaluating who i was
and because i continually reevaluate my
belief kept changing it kept changing it
kept changing and of course my results
kept changing my results were a
reflection of my own belief
i just know that
if i get an idea i can execute that idea
i don't know how long it's going to take
me i don't know
where i'm going to get the resources but
i knew i do know it's going to happen
that's what william james said believe
and your belief will create the fact i
think there's a lot of people writing
books that really don't understand what
they're saying
and
their understanding is very shallow
i think the secret to
understanding how to really get to know
ourself we have to go to people that
have demonstrated by results they really
know what they're talking about like i
always say that 80 of the people that
are teaching have never done what
they're teaching
and if you haven't done it i don't think
you really understand it so it's not
what you know it's what do you do
and
for years
companies were paying people
based on what they thought they knew it
was gone by a degree
and the degree didn't indicate they knew
anything at all
it meant they had gathered information
but
i think we have to go by what they do
i was very fortunate
when i started to study
the first man that helped me the first
person that helped me was a man
and he's the one that
introduced me
to this book
this i've got to help with an elastic
now let's think and grow rich
by napoleon hill
and
he knew what he was talking about
and he said if you do exactly what i
tell you you have anything you want well
i didn't believe that
but i believed he believed it and he did
and he did know what he was talking
about
so i was
i feel i was particularly fortunate
in that i met someone like that
and
i think probably it was an unconscious
thing in the beginning
if i followed anyone from then on
i looked what they were doing before i
started to listen to them
i looked at their results before i
started to pay attention to them
and that has been sort of a
a guiding principle in my life
i believe if you want to learn something
you have to go to someone that knows
more than you do
and that's really what i've done
and i've had five or six people that
i've followed
over the past 60 years it's been 60
years since i started to study this
and
i followed that principle and i think
it's a it was a good
sound principle to follow if you're not
calm
you're tied up in a knot
you
solve nothing
energy
flows to and through us
when we're up tight it's like putting a
kink in a garden hose and wonder why the
water doesn't flow freely yeah if you
want the energy to flow freely through
you and get good results you've got to
become
so
the trick is
don't let anything outside really upset
you
now there's another side to this
if you let something outside get you
excited
you're going to let something outside
get you depressed
because you're reacting to what's going
on outside so something really good
happens you get excited something bad
happens you're going to get depressed
that's because you're letting the
outside control you
i don't think you should get excited
about anything i think you should get
enthused about it see
excitement
has a polar opposite
and it's depressed
enthusiasm doesn't have a polar opposite
enthusiasm is in god it comes from the
latin and theos
in god
and it just is
just is neither good or bad just is
everything just is in truth you know so
it's a bit of a philosophy you got to
get into and then you train yourself to
think and live that way so you're
building an idea
and you're planting it in universal
intelligence
now when you do that
when you do that what you want to
understand
is that
you planted that idea
here
that idea then
is planted in universal intelligence so
it's drawing from anywhere
anything that's in harmony with it
you see this
is a vibration
it's a frequency
and we have put ourselves on a specific
frequency when you hold that idea when
you're emotionally involved that must be
expressed within through you whatever
you need is in the universe and this
idea is going to attract it to you
because the idea controls the vibration
that you're in the vibration you're in
controls what you how you act but it
also controls what you attract
this is very important you get this your
subconscious mind is um
it's like universal intelligence
and
that idea then um
on a specific frequency
hold on
we're spiritual beings
this is the spiritual side of you now
everything spirit
the intellect and the physical
but when you plant the idea here
it's planted on a specific frequency
it's almost like
when i phone somebody what i'm doing is
i'm tuning in on a particular frequency
and they're on that frequency
and when i press a number their phone
rings doesn't matter where they are
they could be anywhere in the world you
see when it comes to universal
intelligence you eliminate all time and
space there's no such thing as time and
space everything's in the now everything
is in the now
and it's important that we understand
that
and when we understand it good things
start to happen to us
okay
now that idea
will attract to it
anything that's in harmony with it
so whatever you need will come to you
but it won't come to you before you need
it
and we're very impatient and we want to
do
this part before we get this part done
you've got to do things in the order
you see this part is operating by law
it's operating by law
because it's universal intelligence and
the law is perpetual transportation of
energy that idea instantly begins to
move into form
and it attracts whatever is required but
it also causes you to act the way you
have to act so it's the action and
attraction that ultimately produces the
result
how long does it take for that to
manifest we don't know
that's governed by a law called law of
gender that law decrees that all things
have a gestation or an incubation period
here you have your senses see here smell
taste touch
you also have an imagination your
imagination
is a magnificent hill said it's the most
marvelous miraculous inconceivably
powerful force the world's ever known
there's a power flowing into your
consciousness
it never stops it flows to and through
you you can actually photograph this
energy leaving your body
you can learn to read it too i could
read your energy like a book
now as this energy comes in your
imagination gives you the ability to
build the picture
and you can build any picture you want
and what you want to do is with your
imagination build an image of something
absolutely incredible
and then
you turn it over to your subconscious
mind this is the part the early greeks
called the heart
that's why solomon says as a person
thinketh in their heart so are they
because whatever is impressed has to be
expressed
so it's the image that you impress that
controls the vibratory rate of the
physical body
i was working with matt who's our in our
creative department
and
today and we've been working on a
special video that we're going to be
putting out you're going to you'll hear
about it and it's on
attraction the law of attraction
you see the law of attraction is a
secondary law it's not a primary law if
you don't understand the law of
vibration you're never going to
understand the law of attraction
and everybody's impacted by that
well the visualizing is use the
imagination you've got to sit down and
become the actor and you start to see
yourself with the good that you desire
and then as you start to impress it this
is your emotional mind this is your
intellectual mind this is your emotional
mind and as you pass this over to um the
emotional mind it sets up a vibration in
the body
and that's called feeling
so you're going to feel yourself already
with the good that you desire
now if you have to write a little note
to yourself and carry it around and hold
it in your hand and you just take a
little note and hold it in your hand
every now and then stop for a few
minutes
go sit somewhere by yourself
and totally relax tell your body to
relax it's your body you're not a body
you live in a body so say just relax
just relax
in fact try this right now
let all the muscles in your stomach
relax then we'll relax
let it all hang up come on just let it
hang out
now
let your jaw relax
just let it relax you didn't even notice
your jaw wasn't relaxed just let it
relax now get yourself into a totally
relaxed state and then start holding the
picture and getting emotionally involved
with the good that you desire
i mentioned something yesterday i'm
going to mention again because i think
it's very important get this book
this is stella adler's book
the art of acting it is an incredible
book
really good
she was marlon brando's teacher
art of acting
you want to act like the person you want
to become way back 1900
william james said that it's the actor's
technique one of the best bits of advice
that you were ever given
well to study
um
never stop studying
hmm i um
i was in here in the studio
quarter to five this morning
and
these are
things i was working on this morning
um
i have pieces of literature that i study
every morning
are you familiar with this book
power of awareness
no i never want to make myself aware of
it power of awareness
and it has a red band across the bottom
make sure the maroon band
because there are different books this
is power of awareness by neville
but make sure it's got this red band
across the bottom
done now he said determine imagination
thinking from the end is the beginning
of all miracles
that is so good so you imagine yourself
you've already done it you're already
there
and he said the future must become the
present in the imagination of the person
who would wisely and consciously create
circumstance
well
i've been studying this one page
for days
and i was on the phone with sandy
gallagher from about 8 30 till 9 this
morning we were studying this one page
together
and we were talking about where we would
apply it
um
the secret i think to growing
is study and if you don't study you're
going to stay where you are
you have to keep studying i learned how
to study by
when i worked with earl nightingale
and
i've got a book holder here on my desk
that has a book open
now i've been reading those same two
pages for maybe three months
and it's the repetition of the
information
that alters the programming in our
subconscious mind see the only criteria
you have to have when you set a goal is
do you want to
do you want it doesn't matter how you're
going to do it it doesn't matter where
their money's coming from
i once heard a create a story where the
maharashi when he was taking
transcendental meditation or decided he
was going to take him to the world one
of his close associates said
where's the money going to come from he
said wherever it is right now
i always thought it was such a beautiful
answer because the truth
everything you need everything you want
is already here
nothing is created or destroyed i didn't
dream this up
it's the way it is all science all
theology tell us that the way to get the
moon was already here always here
when president john kennedy asked dr
warner von braun who's considered the
father of the space travel what it would
take to build a rocket that would carry
a man to the moon and bring him back
safely to earth von braun answered him
in five words the will to do it
the will to do it will is a mental
faculty that gives us the ability to
concentrate you got to concentrate on
what you want that's all you can
concentrate on and that will keep you on
the frequency that you have to be on to
attract everything that you need to get
there
this is so important
to see i believe decision where it all
starts
it's where it all started for napoleon
hill
it all started when carnegie asked him
are you prepared
to dedicate the rest of your life to an
idea
for which you'll probably receive no
material compensation
for at least 20 years how would you
answer that
you see he didn't know how to do that
he didn't even believe he could
do you know what i found when you set a
goal you don't have to believe it
if you keep repeating it you'll come to
believe it
if you tell yourself a lie often enough
you'll believe it
way back in 1900 william james from
harvard he said believe that your belief
will create the fact
so true
so true and so misunderstood
so what do you want
compare your dream
to napoleon hill's idea
just compare it for a moment
your idea is probably small by
comparison
but if you don't know how to do it if
you don't know where the money's coming
from if you don't know where the help is
going to come from
you'll probably seem large
when i took my pen
and i sat down and i wrote i would build
a company that operated all over the
world
i had no idea how i was going to do it i
certainly didn't have the finances to it
i didn't have the help i didn't even
have an assistant
i was just me
in my den
writing on a pad
do you know something
today i own a company
along with sandy gallagher who is my
business partner and we operate all over
the world
these aren't accidents
i'm just an ordinary guy
that's doing what the public would
consider something extraordinary but
it's not extraordinary to me and it's
not going to be to you when you start to
understand these principles and
incorporate them into your life i
mentioned we want to build schools in
africa for kids that have never seen a
school
and so we're building them there's many
things we want to do we do them all i
never wonder if i can do something
i just ask myself do i want to
that's why i think god meant us to live
i believe we're doing god's work
somebody said what god's word god well
if god's a creator then god's work would
be creation we've been given the mental
faculties to create
we've been created in god's image
somewhere along the line way back when
somebody got that mixed up
[Music]
they thought when they said you're
creating god's image that god was
created in their image so they're
looking for a man on a cloud there is no
man on a cloud
but i'm going to tell you something
you got some phenomenal stuff locked up
inside of you you bring it to the
surface
you can have anything you want
it's a great way to live the world is
mine it can be yours my friend whenever
you pretend
pretend you're happy when you're blue
it isn't very hard to do
and you'll find happiness without an end
whenever you pretend now the law of
polarity decreases everything is an
opposite you couldn't have an in without
a note or an up without a down or a hot
without a cold
every positive has a negative so every
problem has an opportunity now the truth
is there's no such thing as problems or
opportunities everything just is it's
how we look at it it is what it is
that's it
now if we see something bad why don't we
say hold on a minute it's my perception
that's messed up here if i stare at this
long enough i'm going to see what's good
in it there has to be good in it you
couldn't have an insight to a room
without having an outside couldn't
possibly have up without heaven down
that's just the law
of polarity it degrees everything as an
opposite i don't care what you look at
there's an option you see something
really good it's also real bad now think
of this
if it's only a short way up onto my desk
it's only a short way down off my desk
if it's a long way to the top it's a
long ways to the bottom you can't have a
long way up in a short way down it
doesn't work that way they're equal and
opposite if it's very good it's very bad
if it's very bad it's very good so
you've got a big problem get excited
you've got a big opportunity
how do we reshape our self-image to
serve us as opposed to bring us down
well
it's interesting malts
maxwell malts actually discovered
self-image as we know it today
he was a cosmetic surgeon
and he found
if he operated on a person maybe they
had a distasteful scar in their face
and he removed the scar
he said
sometimes there was a phenomenal change
in the person's personality
but he said other times they'd remove
the scar who was very successful no
change in their personality
that led them to postulate that we not
only have this physical image that
reflects back from the mirror
we have an inner image of ourselves
it's how we see ourselves
now that inner image is an idea
and that idea is generally
planted
in our little life when we're infants
and it's planted by
virtue of the the environment that we're
surrounded by
how we're raised if a child's raised
with praise they're going to grow up
very confident individuals if a child is
raised with criticism they're going to
grow up very insecure
so you see this image that we have it's
a picture of how we see ourself
but most of us
that image was planted by people that
didn't know what the hell was going on
they didn't know the war was over and
they were planting they were developing
a little mind
it was a mind they were shaping it like
fresh clay they didn't understand that
it was a kid they're looking after and
we feed them we keep them warm what the
hell you know that's our responsibility
no it was a mind and they were
developing that mind and if they didn't
understand what were they going to put
in well all they could give to the child
is the insecurities that they had
themselves
so that was the picture that the kid
grows up of themselves
now i grew up very insecure
i was born during the depression when i
first went to school the second world
war had just broken out so everybody's
rationed for everything it was hard
times all the men were away fighting in
europe or south pacific there was no men
doing it the women that were there were
driving the trucks they were cops they
did everything so it wasn't a whole lot
of time
used for developing a little mind
so i just grew up and
picked up what i could
i grew up very insecure it wasn't until
i met a man that gave me this book and
gave me some damn good instruction that
i started to pay attention to who i was
and
i have never stopped
being fascinated
with studying me yeah i am the most
fascinating subject
that i've ever come across
and i have found out that you and i are
exactly the same
we only appear to be different
our physical body looks different we
choose different vocations some earns
more or less than the other
but our potential is exactly the same we
both live in a physical body
we both have these higher mental
faculties
we're both spiritual beings we both
drawn an infinite source of supply
we're the same
so the trick i think
for the person that has insecurities
that hasn't got the strongest image they
want they should find a damn good mentor
that's what changed my life we do live
in an ocean emotion
the dynamic law of life is create or
disintegrate you're never going to stay
where you are following what we're
teaching
you're going to create
it's a beautiful park
so we're looking at our results and
we're saying but this is where i really
want to go and we point to a star that
we're shooting at and we make a decision
that's what i'm going to do
unfortunately
everybody does that
and 90 some percent say when this
improves then i'm gonna do that
do you know
it'll never happen
it will never happen
because you're not on the right
frequency and you see what happens here
pretty soon the decision fades
and when it fades
so does the goal the goal
disappears
somebody said i thought you were working
yeah well i am i'm still working at it
do you know what the problem is
you're thinking on the wrong frequency
you see your thought is down here on the
frequency that you're living on
but the way to do what you want to do is
not on that frequency
clearly understand this all science and
all theology the only two sources of
reference we have to go to tell us
nothing is created or destroyed
the way to do anything is already here
space travel we've always been able to
do it we just weren't aware of how
you know the neat little cell phones
we've got that pretty soon will be
obsolete
we've always been able to do that i
remember back we had the party lines
hardly anybody had a phone then when
they got one they got a party line
everybody's on the line
we were able to build
beautiful little cell phones then
do you know the cell phone you've got
has more power as a computer
than the computer that took the first
rocket to the moon it's
magnificent when you think of what we're
doing and it's all in awareness and
that's what you're developing you're
developing awareness
see the awareness to do everything is
already here but you've got to get on
the frequency that it operates on
because everything operates on a
frequency
if you phoned your uncle harry you
wouldn't expect your mother to answer
the phone
why because you dial harry's number
you got on harry's frequency that's what
the number is it's a frequency
and there's a zillion of them we know
there's an infinite number of
frequencies
everything you want is already here
what you have to do is attract it
and you know something you're going to
learn how to do that
you see
what we really have to do we need to
make a paradigm shift we're programmed
to operate the way we're operating why
would 97 or 95 of the population keep
using a losing formula
they don't know they are
they're giving it everything they've
done we to shift
our thinking
we're gonna shift the paradigm do you
know many of the beliefs and the ideas
that are controlling your
decision-making right now
they were established by some great
grandparent who lived in a different
time but all that stuff is passed down
in the genes
it's called genetic conditioning we got
to change that
you see well you're thinking way down
here on this lower frequency
the way to do what you want to do is a
way up here on a higher frequency and
what's required
is a committed decision
a committed decision
is when you do it regardless
and when you make a committed decision
this is what i'm gonna do
you flipped your brain onto that higher
frequency
and the way you shown
now we're gonna talk about your sixth
sense
your intuitive mind because that's how
it comes to you you're tapping into
universal intelligence
that's what all highly successful people
do whether they know they're doing it or
not is irrelevant
but that's what they're doing that's
what you're going to learn how to do we
have here in the country subconscious
the paradigm and part of the paradigm
with respect
to money
is
it's a poverty thing
now this paradigm
impacts our thinking there's a power
flowing into our consciousness
and the thoughts we think
are generally
motivated by the subconscious mind
now something that i've been
pointing out here recently
on look at this
the subconscious mind is universal
intelligence
so when you have that paradigm in the
subconscious mind
that controls the vibration that we're
in
and the vibration we're in is going to
dictate what we attract because we're in
that vibration here on a conscious level
on a subconscious level and on a
physical so you're going to attract from
anywhere you go in the universe the same
type of thing that's that's what we're
attracting
so we're attracting people that are in
harmony with this and this paradigm
causes our thinking to be along the same
level
now
we've got to realize even in our
ignorance when we don't know and we
haven't got anything
our thinking is hooked into universal
intelligence and you will attract from
wherever it is in the universe whatever
is required
to cause the problem when you hear
people say you know i just get one film
bill paid and another one pops up
bang they're gonna attract it and sure
as it gets dark they get it
now that's ingrained in our mind from
the time we're children
in fact
from the moment of conception in most of
us
and then we grow into it and that's what
we hear is we're growing up money
doesn't grow on trees and and over and
over you can't have everything you want
you know
and
that is
that's got to be eliminated
and we've got to realize that is not
fact
that you do not have to work harder
that you do less
and you earn more
and you've got to get the idea that you
can have money coming in from many
different places in the world dragging
it right into you
you attract it
and you can magnetize yourself
to money
in all different quantities we have to
go way back to 1908. things were pretty
primitive then relative to today we
weren't moving at the speed we're moving
at now
napoleon hill was a young reporter for a
little
magazine and someone probably the editor
decided they would run a series of
articles of interviewing wealthy people
hill was fortunate enough to get an
interview a three-hour interview
with the wealthiest man in the world
andrew carnegie
[Music]
and he went and he sat and he
interviewed him now unbeknownst to
napoleon hill
andrew carnegie was looking for someone
that he could give a big project too
and he hadn't yet found anyone
at the end of the three-hour interview
andrew carnegie said to napoleon yell
napoleon
this interview isn't ending it's just
beginning
i want you to come home with me he'll
say he was glad he took him home because
he didn't have enough money to rent a
hotel room
he spent three days with andrew carnegie
the wealthiest man in the world now
think of this
over those three days
andrew carnegie shared his philosophy
she started out as a poor boy
immigrated from scotland
with his parents just as a boy they
didn't have anything
so he went from nothing to be the
wealthiest man in the world and he
shared with napoleon hill his whole
philosophy
at the end of the three days
carnegie decided that
i think this is the man i'm looking for
i guess you could tell by his level of
interest in the story
the philosophy of what got him to where
he was
there was probably a number of factors
came into play
but carnegie think i think he's the guy
and so he asked him a question
unbeknownst to napoleon hill he only
gave him 60 seconds to answer the
question
and at the end of the 60 seconds he
would have to make a decision a
monumentous decision
if you think about it
he looked at him
he had a stopwatch in his hand under his
desk
and he says napoleon you've spent three
days with me you know now
how i've accomplished what i've
accomplished
is i'm going to ask you a question and i
just want a yes or no answer
just a yes or no answer nepal
he said would you spend or invest the
rest of your life
in an idea for which you would probably
receive no material compensation
for at least 20 years
how would you answer that question i've
asked myself on many occasions how i
would answer it
in 25 seconds napoleon hill said yes he
would
he qualified
he passed the acid test
and he had to make a decision
that was a big decision
you're going to run up against decisions
this is one of the 13 principles
napoleon hill wrote a whole chapter on
decision
in his book think and grow rich
and right on the very first page he
points out that all successful people
make decisions very fast they change
them very slow if and when they change
them at all
and he pointed out that people that are
not successful make decisions very slow
and change them fast and often
i guess that's why andrew carnegie gave
him 60 seconds
if he took longer
he would be disqualified i became
obsessed with learning how to eliminate
doubt
and i've been researching this more and
just trying to learn from people like
yourself on how you
have dealt with self-doubt over the
years and how you think anyone who feels
like they're doubting themselves
what can they do to go from doubt into
confidence what do you think is the
power okay that's a good question it
ties in with the previous question yes
what do we do with fear
fear comes from the doubt
so the doubt becomes the cause of the
fear
which is the cause of the anxiety etc
the doubt is the cause fear is the
effect
what is the polar opposite to doubt
understanding
it's understanding
that's the opposite of doubt
so what is it we want to understand well
if it's me that's entertaining doubt
why am i entertaining doubt
if i were to find out who i really am
and i believe everything that's been
taught down through the centuries i
would have no doubt i would be realizing
that i could do anything
and the only thing that's caused a doubt
is a lack of understanding so i'm going
to keep studying and i'll gain a better
understanding i don't doubt myself i
don't doubt what i can do
does that mean that i can do everything
no when doubt appears i'll eliminate it
and i'll eliminate it fast because i'm
going to figure out how to do whatever
it is i'm doubting yeah
and you see if it's me that i'm doubting
it's because i don't understand me well
enough
i did a broadcast the other day it was
all over the place we had thousands into
it on self-image
and we've got to get a better image of
ourself we have to get a true image of
ourselves understand who we are how our
mind functions
realize this physical instrument we're
living in is nothing but an instrument
it's the instrument of the mind
and the mind expresses itself with and
through this thing we call our body
well let's understand that better this
thing
you get enough power in your one hand to
light up that building you're in for
probably a month wow there's about 11
million kilowatt hours per pound
potential energy locked up in the
electrons in the atoms of the body
well
that's the invisible power that's in me
i want to understand that better how
what that's the physical side what's the
higher side higher side is my
intellectual side and that is the
intellectual factors that i run through
earlier perception of well reason
imagination memory and intuition there's
six of them and
as i understand those more as i
understand my intellectual factors i'm
using the things and i'm utilizing and
developing the things that separate me
from all the rest of the animal kingdom
of which i'm apart
then i can tap into the spiritual
essence of who i am
because we're spiritual beings and
that's where the greatness lies
it lies in understanding the spiritual
essence of who we are you see our
spiritual dna is perfect it requires no
improvement it requires no modification
our spiritual essence is perfect and
that perfection is within us so the
trick is figuring out how to express it
in a greater way i set a goal in 1973
i set a goal that i was going to build a
company and upgrade all over the world
i had uh left the night yo connect
corporation
and decided that i was going to do this
because i didn't agree with the way they
were doing it
people weren't really learning it fast
enough
and they wouldn't get involved in the
repetition we were selling recordings
but the recordings weren't working
because the people didn't understand how
to use them
so i decided i would leave and start my
own company
and i wrote down i'd build a company and
operate all over the world i got a call
last night from mikey about nine o'clock
something like that
and then she told me
that we were now
in every country in the world
now think of that
we had a broadcast going on here at 10
o'clock this morning
some of you'd be familiar with some of
you may have been on it
and
that broadcast had attracted thousands
literally thousands of people
from every country in the world
the goal was reached
that move
meant this is really accurate today
we're only limited by weakness of
attention and poverty of imagination
well my imagination was pretty well
exercised i don't have any difficulty
building huge ideas in my mind and just
figuring out how to do it
now stay with me here
the thing that's stopping you
from taking the risk that you want to
take
is called a terror barrier
the way i'm going to explain this to you
i come up with sitting in a restaurant i
remember it was at a holiday inn
restaurant
it was at dixie and uh just south of the
401 highway
in toronto
a man asked me if i would meet with him
he had a problem
and
i was going to show him how he could
solve the problem
and he explained it so i took a pen and
some paper and what i'm going to show
you here is essentially what i showed
him
now look at this for a moment
there is the process you go through
when you're in a risk-taking vibration
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier and then to
freedom
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier
and then to freedom i think reason is
probably
it's the one that's spoken about by
almost all the great leaders yeah um the
evolving complete unanimous agreement
that we become what we think about
it's our reasoning factor that enables
us to think
um ford says thinking's the hardest work
there is which is the probable reason so
few people engage in it
dr ken mcfarland
is gone for a long time now but he was a
great educator down in kentucky he one
time said two percent of the people
think three percent think they think and
95 would actually rather die than things
now you know that sounds cute
but it's true
if you stop and listen
to what most people are saying
it's going to be fairly obvious they're
not thinking
if you stand back and watch what most
people are doing
it's fairly obvious they're not thinking
or they would never say or do what
they're doing
most people today have their television
on the news
and they're just
soaking up
all the stuff
that's going on that's dominating the
media right now
so they've become a play thing for
what's going on outside
and that's why they're living in such
fear
by consuming the media of whether it's
true or accurate or not true you're
you're being manipulated
yeah it's not a matter of whether it's
true or not
is this how you want to spend your life
just listening to that
um that doesn't mean you should deny it
it doesn't mean that you should say well
that's all false
um
i don't know whether it's true or false
it's just bad news i don't want to be
involved in it yeah am i aware that it's
there well you'd almost have to be dead
not to be aware that it's there but that
doesn't mean you have to spend your time
thinking on that
i would much rather activate some of my
creative faculties and
do something that's constructive it's
pretty well known today there's a lot of
fear in the world
people are wondering what's going to
happen we've gone through many tough
times if you study history
i was born during the great depression
so i was of an age then i remember some
of the things as a little kid
then we went into a world war
and when the depression ended
it was sort of like a theater where the
lights were out it was empty but the
lights started to come up
and things started to get brighter
and of course they became very bright
so
the fear
don't let fear control you fear is a
negative emotion
by following these principles you're
going to be on the other side of fear
where there's faith
there's a law of the universe called
polarity
that law decrees everything has an
opposite
every negative has a positive
the truth is it's neither positive or
negative
it's our thinking that makes it so
everything just is we can make it what
we want
make up your mind now
you're going to go on the positive
polarity you're going to stay with me
because that's where i'm going
and there'll be a very bright future
let the fear go
it isn't necessary
the cause of it is ignorance the cause
of all fear is ignorance if you want
something you haven't got you got to
create a space for it if it's in your
own mind you've got to let go of
something
so what do we want to do to let go if we
want to let go of the image we've got
for the one we're going to build
now
i'm going to be honest with you when i
started to do this
i tested it just
i thought i wonder if this really work
and i found that it really worked
so i went all out
and
you start out by writing
the image that you want to hold
i'll tell you how i did it
i um
i took various people that i really
admired
and i took some of the qualities that i
really admired in them and i'd write
them down
i wasn't going to be like them but i was
going to develop a couple of these
qualities or habits when i was growing
up i was a young guy it was during the
second world war
there was no men around no fathers
but one guy did have a father donny
miller's father
had was not well so he couldn't go to
the war
and
donny's dad had a heart attack or
something it was i think it was a heart
attack
and so we never went around his place
because his dad wanted things quiet
they'd come around our place but not
donny's place
i would watch
donny's dad walked up and down the
street
you see him go way up the street later
on you'd see him come back
he was always well dressed and he had
the calmest walk
there was no rush just a very calm
walk i visualize myself walking like him
you'll very rarely ever see me rushing
anywhere there's no need of it
you can be calm
so when i built my self-image
built it around certain things ray
stanford
always had money
i told you earlier i don't know how to
get into this thing now
always have some money always
now
i hardly ever use it
because i really don't pay for very much
um i get somebody in the company to
order whatever i want
but you see i never had any money ray
always had a roll on him he would have a
roll like that in his pocket all the
time
now there's about three thousand dollars
here this is not a boat there is three
thousand dollars here
you see
well
i only earned four thousand dollars a
year at that time three thousand dollars
would have been a ton of
money
but everybody has different little
quirks
i like to carry money
i and it's probably because i never had
any
and now
i have some money i want to carry it but
you see i started to do that before i
had any money
and i would take
and i would put
phony money in a roll but i would have
the right thing on the outside it was
the thickness of it
my mind didn't know the difference i
knew intellectually the difference and
then shortly i didn't even pay any
difference to that it was the feel of it
i did different things i watched
different people i saw how this person
did this and somebody else did that
i am
i read a lot
so i read a lot of great self-help books
and
i literally did what some of these books
suggested
it wasn't just sometimes i did it
i would follow it right to a t
you'll very rarely see me without a suit
on
that's part of the paradigm
it's part of the paradigm
i don't care what anybody else does how
they dress
i'm always going to be dressed
i
mentally made up my mind one time i'd be
at least
if i wasn't the best dress one of the
best race people in the room
why did i do that
i did that because i was changing how i
saw me
how i saw me i had never gone to school
i had no money i had
dumb jobs
and today
along with sandy gallagher i have a
company operates all over the world
right here on my desk i have sitting
this little
hourglass
well you know i can't put anything where
that hourglass is until i get rid of it
and we find that we want things to come
into our life but we don't create room
for them
nature
abhors a vacuum i remember we were
sitting in the living room having a cup
of coffee
and just visiting and she said do you
mind if we go and sit in the kitchen
there's none at all
so
so i asked her i said
why do you want to sit in the kitchen
rather than she says i can't stand that
room i just hate living in that sitting
in that room she's i hate those curtains
that are on the window and the dining
room and the drapes on the front window
and i said no you don't hate those mark
i said you only have attract things to
you that you love that you're in harmony
with i said if you really didn't love
them you get rid of them
but you say i'm going to put
i'm going to put them there if i get rid
of them i said mark
if you had something to put there you
couldn't put it there because you've
already got something there
and i said that's when i started
teaching the law
of vacuum law prosperity
certainly she went and got a chair and
got up and stood on she started to take
all these curtains down
well done he was wearing like a
stuffed peg he said what are you doing
and she said i'm getting rid of these
and she did
wasn't too long after i dropped in all
the furniture in the living room was
gone
it was like they were just moving into
the place
but then they got new curtains and then
they got new furniture and you know
everything in that business in that
house changed it wasn't too long they're
only in business for themselves they're
both gone now but when they left they
were very well off they had a beautiful
place in florida they'd go to the winter
the family still runs their own business
i mean it was it was such a beautiful
thing to see and it was all and i tell
the story in here because it was all
about the vacuum law of prosperity
well what have you got in your life that
you don't want
or that you don't like
or what is it that you've got that you
really want to get rid of
you've got to get rid of this stuff get
rid of it give it away see nature truly
does abhor a vacuum when you make space
for the good that you desire that's when
the goods going to come most people
don't make the space for the good that
they desire talk about people paying
themselves they pay everything under the
sun but they don't pay themselves
think of when you're on a plane
and
the oxygen mask may drop down
there's a problem with oxygen in the
plane
they will tell you if you have a child
with you put your own on first
because you can't look after the kids if
you haven't got your self looked after
well that's exactly the same with money
look after yourself first if you don't
pay yourself
you're soon gonna
teach yourself and just not do very well
i think we should be thinking about the
uh
the greatness like it's the school of
greatness i think we ought to be
thinking about the greatness that we've
lost got locked up within us and bring
it to the surface everyone has deep
reservoirs of talent and ability within
them
and they can bring it to the surface to
accomplish anything they want
now to sit in fear
and
and wonder what's going to happen
that is a dumb waste of your talent and
your time yeah
and unfortunately
that's what most of the media is uh
promoting right now
to believe in
fear
is to believe in something you can't see
to believe in faith is to believe in
something you can't say well if you have
a choice i think i choose faith over
female absolutely
i think i believe where i can really see
something happen i believe we're going
to have a phenomenal year in our company
in fact our um i am business partner
sandy gallagher
and uh very bright lady
was a securities attorney prior to
joining us
she ran a program this morning for um
our entire company we have about 70
people
in the company she was teaching
masterminding to them all
and saying how this is important that
every one of us get involved in this
that we learn the basics of
masterminding that napoleon hill
brought to the world
let's say
way back in the 30s
now i think that's what we should be
teaching people
sandy was on the right track there so i
think we ought to be thinking about what
we're going to build how big are we
going to do it where are we going to do
it when are we going to start
our goals have not changed
they're very big they're very ambitious
and we're not letting this virus slow us
down one bit yeah as a matter of fact
we're trying to figure out how can we
use this to speed it up mm-hmm
you can't you can't get rid of it
use it to your advantage yeah there is a
way we can use it to our advantage
people are more dependent upon the phone
uh i've got a computer here they're
dependent on their phone their computer
more than they've ever been
we can reach them anywhere in the world
through those meetings now carnegie said
to hill
he said now napoleon
i'm going to introduce you
to some of the world's most successful
people
he says i'm going to give you letters of
introduction
you'll receive no subsidy from me
i want you to go out and write
the laws of achievement
he says it's a shame that people like
myself are going to their grave with all
this knowledge locked up in their bones
he's i want it
organized and i want you to organize it
i will give you letters of introduction
and then you're on your own
now i said you're going to run into many
tough times napoleon no question about
that
so i said i'm going to give you
something
that'll help you through those tough
times
i want you to write this out i don't
want you to write every word no one's
going to underline every word
now he said
this is a message that you're going to
give
from yourself to yourself napoleon
so it's going to be you talking to you
i want you to write down andrew carnegie
i'm not only going to equal your
achievements in life
i'm going to meet you at the post and
pass you at the grandstand
well
as the story goes he threw his pencil on
the floor he says now you know darn well
i'm not going to be able to do that
he says i know you're not napoleon
unless and until you believe
it but i want you to repeat that every
morning and i want you to repeat it
every night i want you to look in the
mirror and i want you to repeat that
looking in your eyes say andrew carnegie
i'm not only going to equal your
achievements in life i'm going to meet
you at the post and i'm going to pass
you at the grandstand
now that wasn't an easy thing for hill
to do
he was living with his brother
he had promised his brother that he was
going to pay for him to go through
college
now he was going to have to go home and
tell his brother he couldn't do that he
or the project that he was working on he
was going to take all his time
and it was going to take every cent that
he could get for himself
then he was afraid to tell his brother
what he was going to do because he
thought his brother would think he had
lost his mind he's going to work on a
20-year project nobody's giving him any
money nobody's going to pay him
the first day he went he locked himself
in the bathroom
and he looked in the mirror and he
whispered
and your cardigan
[Music]
he said he felt when he was saying like
he was a darn fool
because this isn't going to happen
[Music]
but he said i made a commitment that i
would do this so i better do it
so every morning and every night he
would do this now he had committed that
he would do it for 30 days
[Music]
i ran in the middle of the
month he started to think maybe it could
happen
by the end of the month he knew it would
now i've done a fair amount of study in
this over the last 50 years
and
anything i've been able to discover is
that carnegie made somewhere in the
vicinity of 50 millionaires
some people say 20.
i've read 23. i've read 50.
[Music]
napoleon hill has made millions of
millionaires
so you see he did equal his achievements
he went past his achievements and he did
pass him at the grandstand
here's a boy boy a young boy a young cub
reporter for a magazine
how did he do that why did he do that
i think he did it strictly on the belief
that carnegie wasn't going to ask him to
do anything that was unjust
why is it that all successful people
make decisions very fast
and change them slow and he found out
that was true in his research
with all these giants
well you know i have never stopped
studying it
i probably never will stop studying it
and i'm going to show you something
about decision
that has the potential to change your
life forever
you see i wanted to know why do
successful people make decisions when
they have absolutely no idea how they're
going to make it happen
there's a reason for it
now many of them are unconscious
competence they don't know why they do
that's just the way they do it
you can become a conscious competent
that's what i'm going to show you
and you see it all starts with our own
thinking
[Music]
see vibration is the law of the universe
everything vibrates nothing rests
look at the walls around you
they're vibrating they appear to be
still they're really not still look at
them through a microscope you'll see the
energy dancing in front of your eyes
go take a look at the body in the coffin
now you'll think i'm really losing it
here but listen and think
look at the body throw microscope it is
not dead that body's moving it's moving
so fast it appears to be still
and if it wasn't moving how would it
ever change the dust
everything moves we live in an ocean of
motion make no mistake about it
every level of vibration is referred to
as a frequency and the beautiful truth
is we think on frequencies
do you know that every great leader that
has ever lived
every one of them they've been in
complete unanimous agreement on one
point they've disagreed on virtually
everything else but there's one point
they've been in agreement on
that we become what we think about
solomon put it very well he was a pretty
bright guy he said as a person thinketh
in their heart it's not just the
thoughts that are running across the
screen of your conscious mind it's the
ones you internalize
we truly do become what we think about
see the thoughts that we're thinking
produce the results that we're getting
the law of rhythm is a law
and we have a biorhythm we go up and
down we live simultaneously on three
planes we're triune beings we're
spiritual intellectual and physical well
all three is on a rhythm
cycle
and we have critical highs and critical
lows that's when all three parts of us
are on a critical high
all three parts of us on a very low do
you know there's airlines that will not
let their pilots fly when they're on a
critical low they won't let them fly
they just ground them
you can have this charted i have people
come up and ask me questions sometimes i
know what they want to do they want to
chart my rhythm cycle and i give them
the dates and the things they want but
when they bring it to me i don't pay any
attention to it i don't want to know
that i'm on a low swing
i want to know that i am in control of
me and i don't care whether i'm on a low
swing or a high swing i don't make it
good because i'm going to look for the
good in it
so we understand that there's that time
of the month you know that's not just
for the girls that's for the boys too
because that is a rhythm cycle in life
and it affects all three parts there's
going to be parts when you're on a very
high intellectually you have a column of
figures room like that you add them up
another time you add up that column you
have to add it up six times you get an
after an answer every time you're on a
little swing intellectually there's
sometimes when you're on a low swing
emotionally you walk down the street and
nothing's going right there's other days
you walk down you're skipping with the
kids you're singing with the birds
you're on a high
that's a rhythm process of life we are
building a picture
in our mind here this is an idea
we could say it's a goal
then we impress that idea upon this part
of our personality
that's the idea in our mind
now what we've got to understand
is that
this part of our mind the subject of
mind
is actually universal intelligence
and this is really the way it is
when you press the id upon your
subconscious mind
you are
universally everywhere
now to help you think of that
where here's the phone
let's suppose you're in uh
i don't know
buenos aires
and
i'm right here
in north america toronto and i dial your
number i've got you on the phone
time and space means nothing because
i've got on to that frequency
and so you and i can communicate we're
connected
one person's in buenos aires or you
could say singapore you could say
shanghai and another one is in new york
or in toronto but they're connected why
the time and space means nothing
because you're dealing with energy
and you're dealing with laws
now when you impress this idea upon the
subconscious mind the subconscious mind
is universal intelligence
and everything
anywhere in the universe
that's in harmony
that is a frequency understand that
that idea is a frequency
it's operating on a frequency
and so everything that's in harmony with
it
begins to move toward it
because then harmonious vibration and
you attract it
now
throw a slide up scott
look here for a moment
soren kikigaard
wrote something really
great on intuition
he said
listen you gotta listen you listen with
your emotions
we can only get in touch with our own
source of intuition and wisdom
when we no longer depend upon others
opinions for our sense of identity or
worth
we all tend to worship something
the question is
will we worship the god of opinion
or the god of our heart
i found i had less and less to say until
finally i became silent
and began to listen
i discovered in the silence
the voice of god
now look it
you're going to attract to you
everything that you require
to manifest the idea in your mind
thoughts will come to you
it's your intuition that picks them up
and then act on them
and just because you've never gone there
before you've never done it before
that's okay
this is where courage comes in
this is where awareness
and wisdom comes in
see intuition is the mental faculty
if go back to our slide here for a
moment scott
intuition is here
in our conscious mind
it's one of our intellectual factors
we have perception
the will
reason
imagination
memory
and
intuition
right here
now intuition is that mental faculty on
a conscious level
we pick up thoughts
that are flying our way
they're flying our way
what are they
it's energy that's in harmony with you
you've got on the frequency
of this good that you desire
and you're going to start attracting and
that's what kierkegaard said we got to
start listening
we listen with our emotions let's pay
attention to what's coming our way i
didn't like the idea that
when you've lived for so long you've got
to cut out you've got to stop i thought
hell i don't like that idea at all
um
first of all i think where
where i believe we're here to do god's
work god's work is creation
you know
uh
expansion fuller expression greater
goodness
um
if we're going to do that
we're going to be working at it
all the time we're here on this planet
we never stop so age should have no
bearing on it mm-hmm
we um to build this place we
put a couple of million dollars into
this and somebody said how old are you
and i think i was probably 83 when they
started to break ground
they said you're 83 and you're gonna
spend two million dollars building a
studio
and i said yeah like
why not
i mean
you see we let things that
really have no concern we let them
bother us we let them control us
age is a dumb thing to let control you
it's our thinking that controls
everything
that's the one point every great leader
agreed on we become what we think about
well what's a person thinking
i'm thinking if i get old i got to stop
well then you'll stop
or i'm thinking well
if i've been here a long time i've got a
lot of experience i want to utilize that
experience to keep me going as long as i
am here
sandy gallagher is my business partner
love her
she is really good
she was going through a very tough time
personally
a number of years ago
we were in phoenix we were doing a
seminar i had to leave
catch a plane somewhere
and she said before you leave
could we get together maybe for a cup of
coffee
could you um
i want to talk to you and i said sure so
we went across the road to a coffee shop
and we were sitting there
and she said could you give me two or
three ideas that i could do every day
that would help me through this i said
cheer i didn't know what i was going to
tell her but i knew i'd tell her
something
so i said every day
i want you
to take a pen
and write down every morning write down
10 things you're grateful for
but you've really got to be grateful
you've got to feel it you're really
grateful
then i want you
to send love to three people that are
bothering you
they're bothering you you don't like
them
they've got nothing to do with it you're
thinking bad thoughts about them you're
putting yourself in a bad vibration send
love to three people that bother you
and then
take five minutes
and be quiet
just be perfectly quiet and ask for
guidance for the day
everybody in our company does that every
day
she started to do it like that
everything changed
in fact
my assistant gina who's been with me
over 30 years
she was working in phoenix and i phoned
gina i told her what i wanted within an
hour she had a pad printed at kinko's
and had it
the ten things from one down to ten you
know
send love to three people and bother you
be quiet for five minutes
sandy was going to hawaii with her
sister and her mother the next day
she got pads made for both of them and
every morning they started to do that it
changed every one of their lives
we give that out now in a lot of our
seminars and we train the audience to do
it
start every morning write ten things
that you're grateful for
send love to three people who bother you
be quiet for five minutes and ask for
guidance for the day
it's a winning formula have you ever
spent any time wondering how does
everything happen
how does everything happen why does the
night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
in fact in some places it does
but
i spent a lot of time thinking about
in this
at times it almost drives me crazy
but like right outside of my studio here
is a japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the bud bloom and leaves pop
out
and the leaves generally in the spring
are a very deep greeny brown they're not
a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're most
beautiful it is the most beautiful tree
and it's right outside in my studio i'm
sitting here in my desk and
the camera's around me but
out there is that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
every spring they're
greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring
they're always red in the fall and
greeny brown in the spring
think about it
did you ever wonder
why
the tide goes way out the tide comes way
back in
i spent some time in the navy in canada
i was down on the east coast for a while
and i was near the bay of fundy do you
know the bay of fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same up around prince george on the west
coast
you go onto a ship and you might be
walking up a plank just right straight
up and you go off the ship sometimes
you're going right down
that ship goes way up in here and it
comes way down very high very low tide
now some place the tide's not very big
they do have a tide but not too high not
too low
why is it so different one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know
just stayed at a certain length you
wouldn't have to cut it but it would
always look pretty
you know
do you think about this do you know that
everything in this universe happens in
an exact way
not by chance but in an exact way
when john kennedy
the president of the united states acted
asked dr warner von braun who was the
mastermind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring him back
safely to earth
von braun answered him in five words the
will to do it
that's it the will to do it
he knew you didn't have to know how to
do it he knew you had to learn how to do
it but you didn't have to know
to make up your mind you were going to
do it now why did he say that because he
understands the laws
von braun one time said after years of
studying the spectacular mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of god and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise
that we don't even have any difficulty
building spaceship we send people to the
moon and we can time the landing with
the precision of a fraction of a second
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone i see the laws as god's
modus operandi but i'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law
when you and i
get in harmony with the law now we do
that odds are pretty good we should
understand them but when we get in
harmony with the law then i'm going to
tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them i'm gonna
you'll shock yourself with the good you
can do now i've been doing that for the
last 58 years i'm starting to get a
really a reasonable grip on them but i
don't understand them as well as i want
to or would like to
but i'm going to study a little more
today you know i get my
trusty book out here
i'll have to talk to you about this book
that'll be another talk
study the laws
find out what they write what they're
like
what are the laws and then study them
you'll win you ever notice that some
people seem to want to hang on to stuff
that is bothering them they're forever
talking about it they don't want to let
it go they've had a a failure at
something and it's drone they can't get
over it they just can't get over or
somebody said something nasty to them
they don't want to let it go
do you know what we should do we should
ask ourselves everything that happens is
this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of it
you don't want anything in your life
that's not serving you that's not
causing you to grow that's not adding to
the quality of your life
i don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows
the only thing that can grow is the
thing you give energy to
why would you hold on to anything that's
not serving you now i want you to think
about this i'm not going to talk about a
lot about this today because i don't
think i have to i just want to let you
know that if you're holding on to
something that does not serve you
you are making a terrible error it's
going to cause all kinds of problems you
may blame other people or other things
you may blame the situation uh-uh it's
you are the cause of the problem
the man that
told me to pick up this book and read it
ray stanford
he had a saying he used to say to me bob
you're the only problem you'll ever have
and you're the only solution
i think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but i do
understand it
and you know something
i am the only problem i'll ever have and
i am the only solution
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you reject it
do you know the beautiful part about
having an inductive reasoning factor
that's the part that chooses thoughts
you can accept or reject the beautiful
part of your mind you can accept or
reject anything that comes into your
world except to reject it it's a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want the keys to effortless
manifestation check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there created with an effortless thought
and
that is really a thought that's beyond
the mind which kind of sounds
contradictory but when we are in a place
of zero resistance